what are your most pressing concerns
about the political world in which you
are living Flavia you can start maybe
the first thing to refer also to the
table Oberg is that them
to me the big problem starts with the
fact that hands cast up lives for seven
years in a parallel world right so he's
in this super close world with impulse
of course impulses different ones but
you know at first it seems much bigger
than it should be and you know whatever
like he's totally narrowed down to this
parallel world and I think if I relate
this to today's world
I think the democracy cannot bear that
many parallel roads the biggest problem
and I see it a lot among young people is
that they somehow just want their safe
spaces they don't want to like they want
to be mindful they want to be you know
self fulfilled
it's totally decadent it's because we
are so well-off in the Western societies
and things are going so well I don't
bear it any longer I think we're missing
the true change is going on abroad and
outside of our little nice cute worlds
my biggest teacher actually in politics
was my own mother who was a communal
politician for 16 years and she you know
every Saturday she dragged us kids with
her on some farm opening or I don't know
you know whatever some shop opening and
we went that tight attacked attacked and
then she she okay talk to this guy
attack and she was way away you know and
so we just had to get used to talk to
any people person from any background
and what I experienced is that many many
people don't have this they're not used
to this anymore and sometimes I really I
know you know but I feel ashamed how far
away they leads got from just the normal
average person and if we speak that if
we say it is we want to live in
democracy together we simply are
accepting the fact that a Nobel Prize
winner has the same voice as every other
citizen you know and that's that's what
is annoying me a lot and that's what
makes me fear a lot because we should
really get out of the situation yes I
[Music]
think it's true I don't know if this is
like I don't want to speak about this as
if this is only a contemporary problem I
think that this is a human problem I
think that politics has always been
susceptible to converging so that it's
it's not actually about living people
it's about signaling membership within a
particular community I think that has
always been true I think this technology
has changed the way that that manifests
now but I think that it's always been
true that when people align themselves
with their particular political ideology
it is less because they're conscious of
the practical ramifications of like the
policies that that that are consistent
with that ideology and more because
their friends and their family or their
teachers espouse that philosophy and
they admire the people who say it and so
they want to be part of that group and I
agree with you that like the only way to
understand the ramifications of politics
and the stuff of politics is human life
so you have to go out and see what human
life actually looks like not just the
life that you've been born into but
every other kind of life the only thing
that I would disagree about is that I
don't think only elites are guilty of
this I think that it's not like one
reality is more real than another just
because it's poorer or harder I think
that every subgroup is guilty of this
same impulse because like we have I
happen to be a member of the elite I
know I'm very lucky to have been
privileged such that I don't feel
politics in the same way that of
somebody who's born dirt poor on the
street does but they don't know what it
is to live the life that I've lived just
like I don't know what it is to live the
life that they've lived and I think it's
dangerous to talk about somebody else's
reality as if it's more real just
because it's harder maybe it's because
I'm I born in a
a little counter inside Topeka State I
have always feel more close with the
little things and I think I talk about
intimacy in terms of art and I think in
politics has to be the same because
maybe people feels politics like
something far because they are talking
all the time
and we are they are talking politics all
the time Baraka to us all the time about
big things because big organizations big
blocks and no the more important is the
human scale the human scale human
measure and the diversity of voices and
democracy is a polyphony never a unison
for me I think it's like mods or Musa
keys it's a fun absolutely fantasy in
terms of melodic the rhythm is always
flexible there are lots of ornamentation
that's democracy not this path we are
following two uniformed blocks we
haven't developed a language to talk
about big communities that's the problem
like in the sense of course propaganda
has always been accompanying people as
long as the commodity like communities
were here hey it is rather a new way of
expressing language but when we were
talking about climate change for
instance like language is so incapable
of describing what's happening it's like
you look like you want to write
something about climate change and then
you ask yourself a question is it a
catastrophe now like catastrophe is
something that happens once after seven
years it's not a lot no longer
catastrophe you have a crisis crisis is
resolved within the borders of a state
like Greek crisis for instance then
you've got a problem like it's not a
problem like I might have a problem with
a too-tight shirt but like it's not a
problem so like where are the words to
describe what's happening I do feel that
there is something about the way that
politics is done which turns people off
Europe and turns young people off
politics which is the technocratic way
that politics is carried
and you know I think our maybe our
generation you know had a kind of
political awakening because of these
massive you know life-changing moments
like the financial crisis 9/11 war in
Iraq so many different things but before
that I think a lot of people were
disengaged because of the way politics
is done I think the whole representative
democratic system has to develop new
mechanisms for actually engaging people
and I think you find that when it does
offer new mechanisms people are
interested so for example if you look at
the practice of citizens conventions or
citizens assemblies where they've been
done people come forward they're
interested you know tens of thousands of
people volunteers absolutely my
experience in Tunisia as well is that
you know I work with the most disengaged
young people who don't even believe in
democracy and I work with them for two
years and afterwards they stand for
election in a democratic system and so I
think it's about creating spaces and
about not seeing democracy as a product
that's going to be consumed by citizens
that are sitting there but a dynamic
system that has to constantly look for
new ways to connect with people when
things are changing when we have
technology we cannot you know and
cultural change we can't expect
democratic institutions to remain
untouched they have to change the way
they engage with citizens
you